the runtime for it chapter two has been
revealed and it's a doozy director Andy
muschietti confirmed to Digital spy's at
the its sequel clocks in at 2 hours and
45 minutes a runtime that epic may send
some moviegoers with small bladders and
restless legs running for the hills
but Mosquitia has promised that the
lucky few who have already seen its
chapter 2 in test screenings haven't had
a single complaint about how long the
film is the director explained that the
lengthy runtime is simply the amount of
time the story needed in the long
awaited it follow-up and the extra 30 or
so minutes in comparison to the original
were totally necessary any other length
would have meant dragging the story out
or clipping it too short 27 years
I dreamed of you muschietti explained
further a movie is very different when
you're writing the script and you're
building a story compared to what the
final product is at the beginning when
you're writing and building the beats of
the story everything that you put in
there seems very essential to the story
however when you have the movie finally
edited and it's four hours long you
realize that some of the events and some
of the beats can be easily lifted but
the essence of the story remains intact
you cannot deliver a four-hour movie
because people will start to feel
uncomfortable no matter what they see
but we ended up having a movie that is 2
hours and 45 minutes and the pacing is
very good for those iron bladdered
viewers who actually would love to see a
four-hour version of its chapter 2 you
may not get to experience such a thing
in cinemas but you'll surely be able to
watch it from the comfort of your own
home it chapter 2 producer Barbara
muschietti noted that there will most
likely be a lengthier director's cut of
the film presumably included in a
version of the film's home release she
said we will put out a director's cut
because this time it definitely merits
it we have some amazing scenes that
didn't make it into the movie you have
to make choices sometimes and some
things cannot be in this theatrical
release but are definitely worthy of
people seeing them at a later date but
fear not fright fans all the super scary
scenes are featured in it chapter 2 not
left for an alternate cut director
muschietti promised that quote
everything that is too scary is in the
movie which we can assume are all those
horrifying scenes featuring a smarter
more manipulative Pennywise the dancing
clown and the sequence that features
thousands of gallons of fake blood to
make what has been reported to be the
bloodiest scene in film history the
movie is also confirmed to include two
controversial storylines from the book a
hate crime that wasn't included in the
1990 miniseries adaptation and a
domestic abuse plot that was 165 minutes
is a pretty hefty runtime but it makes
sense in context it chapter 2 has a lot
of ground to cover
picking up 27 years after the events of
the first film to follow the grown up
losers Club considering it has to cover
a huge swath of Stephen King's more than
one thousand page knob
it's kind of a wonder the filmmakers got
away with a runtime that came in at
under three hours and for context it
chapter two clocks in at 17 minutes
shorter than Avengers endgame fans
flocked to the theaters in droves to see
that film which has gone on to become
the best earning movie in history and
largely found no fault with its
substantial length it stands to reason
that if the biggest superhero movie of
2019 was super-sized and still performs
that well at the box office then the
biggest horror movie of 2019 should have
no trouble raking in big bucks
regardless of its runtime can you idiots
of taking anyone right shut up or change
yeah shut up Richard it chapter 2 floats
into theaters September 6 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about it chapter
two are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]